oh
it smells like fart
[Music]
when josh marshman and i get into the
kitchen anything can happen
so today we wanted to challenge
ourselves to do something we've never
done before
using both our backgrounds and fine
dining what would it look like if we
made a super fancy
modernist burger using the principles of
molecular gastronomy
you know using tweezers foams and gels
pinkies up vibes
and better yet cook it in a giant
mansion just to set the mood right
so he went for it and let me tell you it
was hard work
hours upon hours of preparation was it
worth it in the end we'll leave it up to
our buddy
youtuber codyco to let us know if we
failed or hit the mark
god help us
cody cody welcome to my lair thank you
for having me man i'm stuck
i feel like i'm in like a sons of
anarchy table you know and like
i'm like the guy who like owes you money
where's the gavel at where's the skull
at
come on bro what kind of set is this
we're gonna give you an acid trip of a
meal we like deconstructed re-animated
killed brought back to life frankenstein
and then re-animated again
to create a burger
cool actually you know what i'd love to
hear i'd love to hear uh what do you
think we made
well someone along the way said
something about gastronomy i think even
the first time you called me you were
like it's a gastronomy thing
so i'm picturing like little dollops of
beef like and you know
i'm picturing like a oh yeah there's
dollops of
stuff there's dollars there's dots i've
never had like experimental
scientific food this is just gonna be
more of like a burger that hopefully
you've never had anything remotely close
to this before
i'm pretty proud of what we're going to
make i think we did good yeah i'm ready
to show them yeah
you ready i cannot wait
[Laughter]
i'm starving i can't wait let's get into
it let's go
we preach meat cheese bun this is the
opposite this is the complete [ __ ]
opposite
we're doing a modernist burger it tastes
like a burger but doesn't look like a
burger
we're not really stepping too far away
from a burger we're holding the soul of
a burger
and then just putting it in a different
body so to translate that
that means that we have to spend days to
create
a hamburger which usually takes seven
minutes to make it's a hamburger
it's a hamburger we're taking something
that costs usually
four to eight bucks and literally my
salary
his salary for three days this is a
[ __ ] 15 000
this is easily the most expensive burger
ever produced just to show you how
hardcore this burger is
let's go behind the scenes and look at
the footage of what we did
two days in advance just for you
wow that's really [ __ ] hard so this
beef is [ __ ] primo
[Music]
tastes like a pickle though flour oil
water or is it oil water flour
[ __ ] it we'll do it live how
[Music]
everybody just stay calm please so the
easiest part of our day
is the hardest part of our day i don't
know my name is
oh
this is why you wear non-slip shoes when
you go into a restaurant okay
don't be a [ __ ] idiot like me show us
how it's done bro
okay so we're first gonna make a cheese
foam we've got toasted brioche to
represent
the bread it's essence of the bread it's
the life represents
got cheese we're gonna combine the two
we're breaking them
up and then consolidating and then
consolidating them and then
reconfiguring
you know there's a lot of foams that
people use in fine dining there's a
reason why
if it's aerated technically it hits all
your you know taste buds and everything
so technically you could
taste the full flavor better when it's
aerated also textures are very important
in this style of cuisine that's right
first i'm going to blend the brioche we
got gruyere
we got a little bit of gouda technically
pronounced howda i was yelled at for
that
howda howda cream goes in
directly on boiling hot
let me taste test this real quick
delicious
[Music]
oh [ __ ] yeah aerate the [ __ ] out of that
thing
this is a whipped cream canister like
the old old old old-school kind
and you use nitrous to aerate it
oh that's when you know it's on aerate
it up
there you go oh there you go it's foam
so next
i have pressed meat inside this it has
like textures
of short rib but the fattiness of
brisket you basically confi all this so
it was nice and tender and fatty
and beefy specified it pressed it in
this mold
and then poured a little more beef fat
to sort of soak any crevices to
solidify it into one solid piece
basically so we reanimated this yeah
this took three days to make
i think it looks kind of gross right now
but it's gonna be really good
so basically we're just gonna cut these
into portions
it's like a snickers bar oh did you hear
that the sound that it made when it came
off the board
oh this is squishy
this is the onion element plus garnish
you're probably wearing a hairnet right
now but i want them to curl
so i'm just going to drop them in a
little bit of ice water yeah molecularly
they're going to curl
how many times can we get a molecular
counter what's the number of molecular
times he's been molecular molecular
we're changing the molecular structure
i don't know i actually don't think we
are changing the molecular structure at
all by icing
pan's hot this is hot okay so this is
going down a little press
you have to hear the sizzle it could be
a little hotter i'm cranking this up to
start that soldier boy
yes chef i'm 38.
give it a quick flip oh yeah
so even if you're making a really fancy
burger like this
erotic still need to have the
fundamentals which is
a perfect sear that's right i don't know
why my hand's doing this
we're fine dining we're fine dining we
have to be pretentious
you don't know what you're talking about
so don't look at me
when i'm making my short rib stick
that looks so good it really actually is
a beef candy bar for real
and then on to the serviette to drain
we're actually ready to assemble believe
it or not
let's assemble thank you
the most important part of this style of
cooking
is how it looks plate time so offset
on the plate a little bit to the left
um we have our mustard
caviar we basically just took mustard
seed and pickled it
so it looks like mustard caviar but i
mean mustard is a huge part of burger
making like mustard seared burgers
animal style this is basically a really
fancy animal salt burger
boom boom boom that's molecular now this
this is our pickle food gel i got it
ready for you by
taking the entire jar of dill pickle
chips
and pureeing it and then running it
through four different
filters so that it was just the pure
essence of dill pickle
so i'm just gonna do little dots
carefully
give it a little gas and then this is
gonna go straight on
across it has to look like it's growing
from there
yeah you have these lovely twills a
twill is basically
a wafer little crisp it's like a savory
little wafer so this is gonna replicate
the sesame seeds
on a sesame bun oh [ __ ] that really does
look like a forty thousand dollar burger
this could be like one of those shots in
tik tok where they're like
next with any good burger we have to do
french fries
and make a parisian gnocchi it's
basically
potato puree eggs and some salt and a
little bit of flour to hold it together
and then we're going to pipe it out and
fry it pipe it up
you did that to me earlier i'm sorry you
deserve it yeah pipe it up
pipe it up sorry okay into the fryer
i have ketchup leather and i have
dehydrated tomatoes that we're gonna
turn into the tomato powder that will be
the side dish and we're gonna play down
this beautiful live wood so it looks
like it's like very earthy
unbelievable guys this isn't just wood
this is with wood from like
generations ago he this was at the top
of a mountain
kill the bear because there was a baby
the baby was
was late that was sleeping on this and
we were on the top of the
and i got it and i and i got it it was
crying it was crying
and i was like no no no no don't cry
i'll save you you remove the wood
instead of picking the baby so
i took the baby i put the baby down i
took the wood and i said
holy [ __ ] this would look awesome with
fries
let's stop messing around we're on a
tight schedule
let's make a powder
[Music]
that's powder i did something right all
my old chefs
suck it this is dehydrated ketchup it's
basically a ketchup fruit roll up so
wait are you gonna do ribbons or what
are you doing with it i think i'm gonna
make like
swirls yeah ribbons that's what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do ribbons thank you
for that
thank you chef for the inspo yes of
course you're such an influencer
give me a square dance of that
do you like it actually yeah i do okay
as long as i impress you we're fine
i don't care about cody just kidding i
care about cody
boop can you define what that is
this is a potato french fried beignet
tomato dust this is key
see that's the thing there are certain
things that just look egregiously
pretentious in fine dining
but it actually has a really useful
purpose
i'm just gonna like put ribbons on here
look i'm not
the [ __ ] craziest fanciest guy in the
world right
and you have to use tweezers to plate
and there it is
fries with ketchup guys what is going on
here
dessert dessert so we're gonna make a
root beer granita it's icy it's
refreshing it's the
soda element but we're not doing a soda
course we're gonna do a dessert course
this is the root beer that we froze
solid but i made my own blend i bought
three different kinds of root beers and
i poured it in here
that's fine dining that's fine as dining
can get cream first
i'm not gonna measure it because we're
literally just making whipped cream it's
not that complicated now is it
a granita is kind of like a little bit
between a slushie
and a snow cone and you literally just
scrape it and you get these nice little
root beer flakes i mean look at this
dude
oh sh beautiful did you just chef kiss
a chef's kiss the root beer dude i
didn't know people did that
yeah well against my recommendation we
also got
terrariums yes put a little dollop
our blended root beer granita that's
gonna go off to the right side
so it's offset put together all set
thank you god bless some of these i'm
using tweezers knob and just like you
you have to
okay and i'm gonna kind of make these
look like they're growing out of the
cream
voila bone apple tea burger
fries root beer float made by science
stunning doesn't look like it but when
you eat it all
you're going to be like damn that's the
best i don't know about best
damn that's a burger fries and a root
beer this is a 75
a person burger meal all right cody
be prepared we're gonna blow your mind
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh it smells like fart
that smells amazing that's the burger
okay
it looks like a little protein bar yeah
that's definitely a protein bar
it's a protein that's correct what you
have here
is you have a confit short rib cake
followed by a brioche gruyere foam
mustard caviar pickled fluid gel
and a sesame coral twill i didn't
recognize about a third of the words
that you said and that's that's what
we're going for as as chefs i think the
goal is always how do we confuse the
[ __ ] out of the dime yeah yeah yeah
right it's a moose bouche
yeah i'm about to amuse your mouth yeah
what is this um this is my
version of french fries oh a potato
parisian
gnocchi and then there's ketchup leather
with tomato powder
how do you recommend he eats it you
should try to get every element
into each bite that's that's the bite
yes that's the perfect bite
what are we thinking off the bat very
rich
short rib is very like tender and fatty
and
really like good yeah it was confide in
tallow
i'm like very pleased
also let's go i'm pumped to try these
because they look like beignets
yeah that's my favorite thing that's
pretty much what it is it's basically
fried dumplings
with ketchup leather let's go these are
amazing
like the mouth feel is super crazy like
you'll be tasting ketchup for like the
next three minutes
maybe like three hours you're gonna be
sweating ketchup for the next three
years
it feels very gastronomical
oh i feel weird because this is the
burger show and i'm like
that's not a burger but honestly guys it
tastes like a burger this is directly
against
burgers yeah if you eat it it [ __ ]
tastes like a burger
what do you think a burger like that
should cost
this right here yeah i think 35.
oh 35 that's a slap in your face
is that cheap or is that expensive no no
no we're not done what really
oh we have one more thing
[Music]
this is a root beer float what
you have a root beer granita it's a try
root beer three different root beers oh
wow okay
a vanilla bean chantilly and some micro
greens
[Music]
oh that's great right that feels super
fine dining yeah eat
19 of those yeah the little lettuce
little greens on there
actually was awesome cleans it up a
little yeah it really does
you know what i was kind of missing is
the bun i knew you're gonna say that the
bun was
on that plate where in the cheese foam
how so we got
the brioche pulverized it and put it in
there
interesting that's always what happens
when you do food like this
yeah it's always a loose interpretation
or an inspiration of a burger
there's michelin star and then there's
cody stars okay
how expensive is food at at three
michelin star restaurant
pretty expensive you go with two people
it's gonna be over a thousand dollars
okay so what's that divided by 35
we got a one star we got one we got one
still got one cody's song
i'm entirely joking though i would give
it three stars
three cody stars out of how many 64.
cody joshua this was a great experience
thank you for being our guinea pig thank
you for having me i really appreciate it
it was delicious are y'all ready for
some real burgers though yes
wait where are they i know the right
people will call
[Music]
what's up burger world thank you for
watching make sure you hit that like
button
smash that subscribe button ring that
notification bell
if not for me for the burgers
i love you